drei menschen die ganz persönliche
erhalten sich im kulturleben zu
engagieren und als freiwillige
produktion
das war familien festival in baden gilt
als boutique festival für internationale
neuentdeckung der musikstudent fabian
bösch ist der troubleshooter im
freiwilligen team
er war bei der bandauswahl beteiligt und
betreut die helfer an einem der
spielorte
hier pflegen die musiker noch keine
starallüren
trotzdem werden sie gut entlöhnt im
gegensatz zu den 60 helfern die alle
unentgeltlich arbeiten im garten im
aargau fabian meier ist
schauspielschülerin und teil des lokalen
kellertheater uns orders nur noch zehn
tage bis zur premiere der eigenen
inszenierung polen liebchen rush
schlüpft fabienne meyer in ihre rolle
die freude am spielen ist groß auch wenn
der druck steigt
auf geht's zur bühne
ein gewöhnlicher donnerstagabend im
hause augsburger wie jede woche
schultert anita augsburger ihr fagott
und fährt zur probe
das orchester des staates turnvereins
barron ist schweizweit eine kuriosität
kein anderer turnverein hält sich ein
orchester freud und leid einer
orchesterprobe ohne lohn zu spielen
heißt nicht ohne ehrgeiz ans werk zu
gehen aber gut bleiben noch einige
monate bis zur großen aufführen
in baden gilt es jetzt schon ernst
den ersten auftritt des abends
bestreitet der isländer julius mevert
fabian bösch ist im vierten jahr dabei
und so bereits ein routinier ist nicht
nur die musik auch fabian misch und der
festivalgründer sind entspannt die
akribische vorarbeit hat sich gelohnt
keine pannen bisher und das publikum ist
begeistert
ich hasse doch immer sein die hätten die
pole
china exportiert
auch polen liebchen ist auf kurs ein
schweizer dorf im zweiten weltkrieg
während die männer aktiv dienst leisten
werden im dorf polnische soldaten
interniert aufregung im harten alltag
der frauen gelöst da ist die stimmung in
baden
und doch ist improvisations kreis
gefragt schon eine lockere schraube kann
den auftritt gefährden
acht tage lang dauereinsatz mit
überstunden
doch der lohn besteht nicht aus gilt ich
würde mit tieren machen
es verbindet einem so extrem dass mit
sammer auf das geländer vor deiner art
festival schafft es dass das meer ist
logisch es ist eigentlich zu sein wenn
sie ihre knall gegeben dass jackson das
eine super gefallen hand und schönen
afrikaans das ist wichtig für mich
red
a
aus dem finanz- und so ist der dirigent
der einzige im raum der lohn bezieht die
laien aber sind motiviert und finden
schließlich zur harmonie
derweil beim festival das behelfsmäßig
fixierte keyboard hält und im schatten
des publikums lässt fabian bösch seinen
emotionen freien lauf
die helfen haftend länge der
norwegischen band pharao beschließen den
abend in baden eine produktion auf hohem
niveau und eine motivationsspritze für
die zukunft
in bremgarten bei bern beendet das
orchester seinen proben abend in
geselliger runde
man weiß was man aneinander hat im
kellertheater besiegelt ein lied die
polnisch schweizerischen freundschaft
für fabian meier 1 erfahrung mehr auf
dem weg zu ihrem wunschberuf
schauspieler